de voir la propagation du nouveau
coronavirus la chaîne appelle des robots
à la rescousse dans les hôpitaux
l'appareil de qui est my world se
déplace seul pour asperger les vieux de
liquide désinfectant et ses rayons
ultraviolets élimine virus et bactéries
dans un rayon de 10 mètres
une flotte de robots de livraison
autonomes se déplace aussi dans les rues
de wuhan
en tout cas chinoise de commerçants
l'égide il veut aider ses clients à
éviter les contacts mais en cette
période de quarantaine et les épiceries
les pharmacies sont tout de même ouvert
pour les produits de base d'ailleurs un
an comme une crème de pénurie de papier
hygiénique a provoqué des bousculades
dans plusieurs commerces la crise du
coronavirus pourrait perturber les
approvisionnements via des détaillants
qui choisissent de limiter les achats de
désinfectant de savon de ripper de parts
[Musique]